foreign
welcome to another wolf language design
review uh another in our series of of
version 13.2
design views and we seem to have a
variety of things here oh wow it's all
kinds of stuff here all right let's
start off units
um Nick yeah so reality changes here not
really our big Focus for this release
was to try and get some of our
fundamental unit operations a lot faster
so The Benchmark section has a breakdown
that we're basically looking at you know
two to three orders of magnitude
Improvement for our fundamental unit
operations
um so those blue bars are the old
timings in microseconds orange bars are
the new ones
good stuff
um yeah so our first pass was one of the
fundamental unit operations unit
conversion and then arithmetic is the
thing we're still working on but they
should all hopefully be faster and then
just knock on effect if everything's way
faster
and then yes temperature was the other
change we made to remove the ambiguity
between temperatures so if I say
something like
uh
you know
200
degrees Fahrenheit
minus
um
minus 10 degrees Fahrenheit
oh look at that Swank
okay
right cool
yes and these now can be used without
ambiguity in formulas from physics like
plant law Stefan boltzmann law Etc
because it would know it when it has to
use the object as a temperature or as a
temperature difference now I assume that
this has been flowed through to all the
other places where we're I mean we won't
have some kind of crazy oops that's the
wrong kind of temperature thing in
Formula data and all that kind of stuff
right nope we did a comprehensive review
of the formula data formulas and made
sure everything looked good there
good work
nice
okay should we move on
yep okay random date
okay
so
what happens if I say random date this
century
okay
all right and if I say random date
we're just fine
whatever
and random time
as similarly I could say random time of
today
and it'll be some random time today okay
fine
I assume that there are no interesting
uh distributions probability
distributions for times
could you say that again
I assume there are no interesting
probability distributions for times
other than uniform
well
um
go ahead
um I mean yes that kind of are right so
for instance
if you measure server traffic or you
know human traff uh I mean like uh
traffic traffic yeah yeah the times
between events has a distribution bustle
or something not exponential typically
okay uh
and but there's a whole slew of other
ones like for for more complicated
queuing models and so on that's what you
vary do people cluster up uh things like
that
uh yeah so there is a sense in which if
it's random time
and those times were you know when cars
would go past this point or when people
were to visit this website there might
be a distribution that makes sense right
it's really the time difference that
there are distributions for if you like
so I'm saying the difference events
I understand which is a little bit
different than
what we have seen
previously with other random variate
type functions where where every
individual
element is picked independently from the
from probability distribution
e
um
right so it's when they say random time
but but it can go both ways but but
typically the time between events is
independent
it's independent and exponentially
distributed for instance that's the
simplest model yeah I I get it but I
mean that means that if I ask for a
hundred random times that would be okay
well but I might want times that have
this exponential difference between them
as opposed to whereas if I ask for a
hundred random uh values of just in
random real
each one of those random reels is
independently picked from a you know
gaussian distribution or whatever no
uniform no no I I know by default that
that's the case but I'm saying that I'm
saying this is a different case because
what is distributed exponentially is the
difference between values yes right
whereas in the usual case what's
distributed however it's distributed
right themselves yeah it's a bit
different
but the difference essentially means
that the center of the distribution
would be a date and the width of the
distribution would be a quantity but it
it still works as with any other
quantity distribution
oh but but Jose what I'm saying is you
ask for a hundred random times and what
we want is this exponential difference
between exponential distribution of the
difference between times
which I claim is a different type of way
of selecting 100 random variates because
they don't have the same Independence
yes I understand that but what I'm
saying is that this can be implemented
by saying we have a gaussian
distribution of dates in which the
center is a date I see and the width is
a quantity which is the quantity of time
differences you are talking about
more or less like we have quantity
distribution as a decorator for the
other distribution functions we could
conceivably have a date distribution or
something like that or piggyback on
quantity distribution uh but it's not
particularly important right now this is
um
I mean I I do think it's somewhat
you know I can imagine for testing
purposes for example that random time
with those exponential distributions
would be of interest
see what I'm saying if you're going to
run tests
um
but uh
I don't think that the design today
prevents us from accepting other
arguments in the future
for instance yeah I I agree
I'm not too worried about this
and there is a work around today
the granularity is actually an option
for random date and random time oh
and why isn't it also an option I mean
we should probably have it supported as
an option to date object even though
date object has this as an argument yeah
I think we'll add it there as well
and why is there no autocomplete here
that that usually takes a build step
I think you won't run down date
okay
okay
yeah I'll follow up on the autocomplete
but it should be getting populated
already oh yeah no problem okay let's
keep going uh before we move on uh Nick
do we want to look at some of the pages
you have a question about quantity right
how to express quantity yeah ref
quantity has a specific tentative note
so the first three notes are inter notes
that we might have but the one we want
to ask about is the fourth this one hell
yep
well it's rather ponderously written I
mean I would say
I didn't understand this um
uh
it should say temperatures in Kelvins
can be added together
but not in but not another scale but
foreign
why don't we rewrite that Jose when we
work later in the week I mean I haven't
seen this before did it just get in or
something yes very recently we wanted to
have a motivation and something to
Marcus knew but I agree with Stephen
it's sort of just
it's the sentiment is right but the you
know the presentation is ponderous yeah
um
now here's a question I mean is there a
way of getting
oh it's not worth worrying about I mean
you know uh from degrees Celsius how do
you derive the you know programmatically
derived degrees Celsius difference as
the different thing I don't think we
care you know if you really care about
doing that you can take a difference
between two quantities like that and see
what the units are
never mind I I was just talking to
myself that's fine okay onward we go
right
okay let's go into the trees
in
right so we added two new things for
visualization and made some other
visualization updates
and then have some suggestions for new
tree Constructors okay all right so
where do we want to go first
let's start with tree
the graph page for tree yep
okay
so I added a tentative note
I don't see it
oh no it's it's already 13 2 plus
options affecting illusion of nodes
include
okay
yep that's what we discussed
all right I mean I think I mean I can
see it run right I mean I could just say
random tree
of 40 comma
Max displayed children
Arrow 3.
okay where's the illusion
so the the root only has two children so
there wasn't any illusion
but what about all these sub pieces
there's things here it all goes to three
oh Christ that's all about this
foreign
what the hell happened here
what the hell happened here
how can that happen that's not a tree
that's a bug I'm gonna have to track
that down well let me send you this tree
before I before anything bad happens to
it
is there a way to like output the random
state right now
is there that's a good question it's all
a random generator state
uh we can try
um
wow I've seen that before that's pretty
Swank
um
that's disgorging the in insights of the
creature okay but here
we should be able to reproduce this and
this is the
you know
well
there you go let me just send you this
because that presumably is going to
reproduce that problem
and I wonder whether that's an election
problem or whether it's something
completely different
ah yeah yeah yeah something very fishy
is going on here I think it's to do with
the illusion
mm-hmm
foreign
problem
and I'm also very confused I mean if I
say Max goes to two
weird
has that same problem again
I actually think I know what's happening
now I think I'm forgetting to increment
a counter when there's a lighted nodes
okay fine yeah okay
um but I think this visually looks nice
there's no mouse over for that thing
though
but what I mean I don't know I like this
this is good this looks really quite
nice
Roger do you have any comments on us or
thoughts about this and Asus
I think it looks pretty good
um
okay fine but I agree I mean I think we
should try to think about sort of mouse
over generally speaking and we should
improve our tool tips for them yeah I
think I think in this case
that having something
you know for nine we could probably one
of the things it could do Ian or Stephen
is to um if you don't want to sort of
expand and blow it all up to just kind
of have a more of a summary table of
properties like there are so many nodes
under here subtrees this and that
statistics basically yeah but even just
saying what these nodes are but but for
nine of them is perfectly doable
those have
yeah they can
okay
yeah the total is giving you the total
number of siblings at that level oh but
maybe on Mouse over we could do things
like you were saying like I mean on one
day you've got to be able to click this
and open it up a bit more
but that's yeah but I think indeed I
think tool tips are are perfectly good
like when you have a when you don't have
paper basically
yeah
all right let's go on
tree outline what's that again
so while we were on this could you just
look at the pages for Max displayed
children and dollar Max displayed
children quickly
just like the usage messages and notes
well this isn't right I mean it says
display I'm children it's totally
confusing because then I'll just say Max
display children Arrow em and it's only
going to apply to the root note
yeah it's like all of these local
options that show the explicit all Arrow
whatever you should show that right
under display and children for the root
node and then you should say list all
Arrow M you should do that for all of
these options where people will
otherwise be just like tearing their
hair out trying to figure out how do you
do it for all the nodes
okay so you should include that in the
table do you think keep the note or
remove the note and which notes
uh all Arrow m
I wouldn't put both of the notes I would
just put it in here
okay
okay but this affects every node not
just the root node correct
okay
and it should probably make it clear in
here
the dollar Max displayed children
effects is the default
display the default number of children
and that default is dollar Max displayed
children right you should say that
yeah but the the confusing thing is
deflate display the default number of
children for every node display M
children for the root node
all our M display M children for all
nodes
you see what I'm saying
well even automatic only affects that
node
but then this is nonsense
you see what I'm saying in other words
does dollar Max display children affect
every node in every tree answer yes
right okay so this is not clear but I'm
saying setting automatic in a given node
only affects that node
I understand that but this is affecting
the default is automatic so the default
for every node is automatic so if I if I
uh you know set dollar Max displayed
children that will seep through every
node by default
right
so you need to make that clear
okay
yep otherwise this looks good okay what
was the next thing you want me to look
at
tree outline
so there's a tentative note
the basic idea is to update this so that
instead of returning an opener view
object it returns something with head
tree outline that just formats
appropriately
that was coincidental they were both 18s
foreign
I'd like to comment that I think doing
something like green with those
with those greater than signs would help
me to understand what on Earth is going
on here
yeah Billy and Noah were working at one
point on a new ux and design for this
we'll have to pick up after 13-2
okay but I I'm suggesting that we just
greenify this slightly
I think that will make it less obscure
and if any other body else has got
comments on this
did he say something
uncompelling about it right now
I mean I'm not helped by the fact that
it that the actual tree has rather
uncompelling elements in it that's true
that's kind of true
um right I mean I assume that some of
these trees from file systems will look
a lot more compelling so let's look at
that when we get to that
can you can you look at the
documentation for tree outline
yeah is there a way I'm trying to
remember that this is what do I do I
press the dot yes
okay
um
I know I was just looking at so the one
thing I'm proposing is that tree outline
now doesn't literally return an opener
view but it just formats
that's fine by me
um and then scroll down
there's this thing where so tree outline
doesn't take won't take these options
directly but the idea is to support some
of the options of tree so if you have
latent from the tree you would have
those same labels in the outline I don't
understand why you wouldn't let it take
those options itself
as an override for the actual internal
tree options
well
you can't actually overwrite options in
that way you just add options
foreign
isn't really a tree itself
some of the semantics don't make sense
really
like like there isn't a parent Edge for
a tree outline for example
so I don't understand so your point is
these are options for the tree which
will affect the tree outline display
if you scroll down I think I have an
example of what it would look like with
XML
um maybe in applications
wow
I'm I'm confused here
yeah
there
I don't know I'll stop what this is
what's that oh that's part of the
expression tree no what is that that's
what positions to have opened
okay
so the other proposal I'm making is that
since expression tree has nice labels
for things that the tree outline should
also use those labels for sure
hey hold on just one second is that the
correct Dom tree
I'll be right back
um I believe so I mean so XML has
additional kinds of nodes for attributes
and we include that in the data but
aside from that
I mean there are some implicit
like paragraph is one of those implicit
ones that that you might have you know
not explicitly marked up
yeah like is that one like a
self-closing tag yeah
yeah self-closing tags are represented
with an empty list of children rather
than as a leaf
so we can't distinguish empty tags from
just text
but when I look at Dom trees displayed
they mostly look better than this
um
I think we should
did I give you the book of trees
I don't have a copy
yeah
that and some some of the actual sort of
Dom tree
uh you know displayers I think are kind
of good examples
um
yeah we looked at the Chrome and Firefox
browsers for XML I think those are both
good actually
mm-hmm
I think we had discussed having tack
column value rather than having it below
that's what I've seen most of the time
so let's say again
we were discussing how to present tags
and and values for XML in outlines
with a colon rather than having one
under Theta the other
yes
but in terms of the tree what are these
what's the payload which part of this is
the payload
so the inner nodes the payloads are a
list with the tag and the list of
attributes
and then leaves are text
to Strings
I mean this is a new thing the
expression tree
what's expression tree outline
what's that
it's a idea for maybe for the future
okay it's kind of functionality at least
just get an outline of the XML directly
without building the tree but but
expression tree of XML is new yes or no
now we added that in 13 1.
the question now is what what to do with
the tree outline of
an external tree is that right
right and and I think one first easy
Improvement is to just use the same
labels
but
other programs and other programs have
additional ideas
for how to render an outline of XML that
might be worth learning from
yeah we are we reviewing this now or are
we not
just just approving the using the same
labels and being I'm very confused yeah
I'm sorry I'm very confused
the underlying XML tree okay so let's
just look at this
the underlying XML tree here
whatever this is
okay so I just wanted to take this this
XML import
ing some random makes a little thing so
now I have
this tree
okay so now I've got this thing
and I don't understand now if you Mouse
over the inner nodes you'll see the
actual payload
which is what now I mean this is
you know written in terms of War XML
does the tag
and what's that in the list though it's
the list of attributes as it would
appear in XML element
okay
okay so the nodes are not XML element
they could be the nodes could just be
XML on them with all of its identicals
in it
it's kind of redundant because XML
element represents the entire tree
not just the the payload at a node
but what what is the XML tree what does
it look like
evaluate XML
no I don't understand why
I see so this is now being turned into
tree of blah blah blah yeah
which
should be there probably like that way
you have highlighted so the node name or
type is sale right then there's no
attributes but then the stuff inside of
it the values basically is next the
third thing
and the fact that this is concept of an
XML element
has kind of you know
that's a past history from before we had
trees yes I mean in the future import of
an external thing
just directly generates a tree I think I
think it should get the Dom tree which
is which is another way of saying what
you're saying
what happens to the attributes then
they're still there
uh you have them in the notes
and and
uh tree was designed to do that right
tree has the ability to store
uh annotations in the notes
well right now we we have the data and
so I I don't normally if you just mean
having a data add a node at all or
having data like a separation of data
and metadata
um
okay but let's go back here so we're
talking about
right now tree outline has a particular
way of dealing with XML trees we also
have a particular way of dealing with
XML trees in the whole you know import
Etc workflow
it seems like we have not yet come to
equilibrium on this issue
of how we deal with XML trees
because I think this is the strong
future driver for treaty functionality
yeah but I'd like to know how I do
manipulation on XML trees Etc et cetera
yeah yeah exactly yeah and for that I
need to know you know I have no idea
what what it's going to look like in
terms of doing that
um
so the first thing that we did was to
figure out how our existing position and
level spec languages work for trees and
we basically finished that in 13-1
so you can use tree extract tree insert
tree delete and they actually understand
the structure of the of the tree
whereas if you do insert delete extract
on XML that's the expression that you're
working with not the not the tree that
it's representing
hey so I mean in terms of sources you
know Sandra is asking here what about
going from the outline
like this to the tree
but I think that outline is like an
opener view type outline
I mean there's there's multiple types of
outlines because there's a
notebook type outline there's an opener
view outline
each one of these could be triified
um
I mean
you know in general expression tree
is a fairly rich and complicated thing
saying how you label you know how you
determine what become the nodes and the
edges of the tree
and XML element is another case of this
let's not get tied up with this right
now because I think I think we need to
separately talk about XML and the
generalization of that okay file system
tree that's the one I want to see here
hmm
yeah this is the type of thing these
structure conversions here okay so what
do I look at next file system page for
file system
so since we've looked at this last the
idea here is to use absolute file paths
for all nodes and then use file names
for edges
okay
that's confusing I mean why
that way you can for example do tree map
over the tree and
you can actually apply a function to the
the file you want because you have the
absolute file path okay how does this
relate to file system map
so
file system this is basically like file
system map of identity
what do you mean I mean file system map
generates a nested Association
right and if you convert that
Association into a tree this is what you
get with expression tree
okay this is like a shortcut for doing
file system map of identity and then
expression treeing it
um
but but isn't this supposed to be sort
of the start of processing so what's
easy processing based on this tree
what are the
what are the things you can do when you
have this tree
well let's just do what we'll look at
file system tree
dollar installation directory right
oh God what's it doing
and I think the version what's it doing
what was it
I think the version of the Prototype
build is not using Association yet
okay but if I say file system tree
and I say
okay let's say I go to two levels here
okay that looks like a mess what do I do
to to see something reasonable here
try tree layout goes to left
um this isn't great
this is um and also do tree element
label function
whatever you're telling me to do is what
should happen by default yeah that's
what I have in the documentation on the
left it's just showing the the base
names
like you just see the base name and then
you get the the full file path and a
tool tip
yeah but so
that's just incomplete what you've got
on the right here is that correct
yeah
the default isn't right but then
how do I specify
the default you are saying
do tree element label function
all Arrow file base name
like this no the symbol
file based name
yeah what is that
is that a symbol yeah it gives the base
name of the file
okay
the heck is this
my God what is this no I see that you
labeled the the directories is that
right from Macos well from script goes
to Wu from script uh oh what's
oh why is that thing called directories
are inner nodes and and ordinary files
are leaves
both directories and ordinary files are
given just like file system map gives an
association where the keys are the file
names this uses the same Keys the file
system map does
but then the thing that file system app
is you have nested associations you
don't have payloads at the nodes so file
system tree is using the absolute file
path as the payload at each node
I understand
that's a directory name right why is
that showing up like a file name
it has an absolute file path and the
label function that it's using is the
base name
what's this that's a directory name
that's the subdirectory so I read down
here
I don't understand this file here and by
the way what on Earth is mathematical
server somebody needs to track that down
and Matt kernel those are not names that
should be there am I making sense
okay I can look into that this is the
wolfen desktop distribution they
shouldn't be that
the difference is the edges are the the
base name and the node data is the full
file path
it's just that we've specified a label
function so that they're both using the
the base name
I mean in a file system everything is a
file but some have attributes that make
them be a directory or Etc
even a directory is a file
but in a tree that would be an inner
node right as opposed to a leaf node
yeah you know it's a f you know it's a
directory because it has an association
in its second argument and files have
none in the second argument
so here we want to say
there's a yeah
I'm fairly confused by this how does it
decide which ones are going to be elated
away
and how come those are showing at the
top it starts it starts from the the
first element of the list
of the list
add-ons why does this go at the top I
understand I would have thought the
United stuff would go at the bottom
this is matching what
uh the graph orientation does when you
say left
the first thing is on the bottom the
last thing's on the top and the screwy
it rotates it 90 degrees to the left I
could screw I don't think it's right
I mean
we might want to address that with graph
as well
I don't think we're going to notice
except in the case where trees which
have ordered uh edges
see what I'm saying
I think it's just not right
foreign
this thing with words crossed out
doesn't look great
what can we do about that
at the very least we can look some to
put some kind of translucent you know
backing behind this or something
also what we've used elsewhere is a
scrim
this which is exactly what you say
translucent backing
and that's what we've done in other
visualization functions yeah okay
so Ian you should learn how to do that
for this
okay what what was that scrim
people respect shadowing where you can't
use Drops shadowing as a style
scrim is just a background
okay
so we've been using it for years it was
invented for smartphones where you hard
up on real estate screen real estate
and so what they do is to show a little
bit of the background but not much
does what I'm saying so if they
completely cover the background that's
that's kind of a problem when you tight
on screen real estate yeah
all right okay what else should we look
at with file system tree
good start
okay now
um
new structure conversions okay we
probably need to look at these don't we
yep
go to expression tree
and then scroll down to I believe scope
um
that's supposed to be documented up here
okay
not an interest if they're not
documented up here
am I making sense
what do you there are notes up there do
you want to look at those notes
about which about this notebook text
element yeah all right okay
okay what what am I looking at
specifically here there's nothing in
this it just says notebook it doesn't
have anything in it
that's the example output for what
converting a notebook into a tree would
do
oh boy
foreign
helpful
what happened there
oh you need to do notebook get
on evaluation of book
that should probably work though
foreign
interesting question whether some of
these expression tree things should
default to left hand
oh layout
if you understand what I'm saying
this is fairly civilized
foreign
she's mad because she's not in the room
hmm you can't get in
I just let the cat in
a cat could join the meeting
as opposed to yeah hopefully the cat is
not in a bag so there's no questions
letting the cat out of the back
um um
okay okay so all right so
well this is a seems like a good start
here
I'm gonna have no sense of whether
um
if I say tree outline of this
oh it is respecting Max displayed
children isn't it
no um he needs to
yeah sure does
okay
what the hell
it's a payload of the root node
okay but that's not great because that's
again an attribute type thing
I'm confused by that you know that
structure anyway what is that structure
why isn't notebook
that's all the so that's the arguments
of The Notebook
minus the nested cells and and its
children like everything that's not a
child
gets put into a list
this is pretty confusing What's
Happening Here
I mean the fact that it says sell
I'm this is pretty damn confusing
what's going on here let me just do your
other categories because it's the same
problem as with XML element you know
sell and notebook they represent entire
trees
so this is trying to represent just the
data that's at a particular node
but yeah but how's that represented in
the in the ultimate tree structure
the attributes what do they look like
because normally it is tree of date of
payload comma list of subtrees correct
mm-hmm
um
you you were saying in the in the review
of code uh trees that there needs to be
a cleaner separation between data and
metadata we just don't have an idea for
that yet
right now everything's just data
okay so so can we please think about
that ASAP
mm-hmm
um
Jose were you asking a question
um
I thought you wanted to have this
labels being shown as the green notes
instead of cells something
is this correct
like in the graph above
yes
exactly so that would hide all these
internal structure
and perhaps although it will be
available in a tool tip yes indeed yes I
see that
okay look look the basic point is
in trees right now
I'm I'm very confused I mean sell
what is the actual structure here
cell is the name of the node
I'm completely confused there are
attributes for that expression contains
a cell group data
which contains a list of cells
right then the remaining arguments are
Styles and then options
goes to an empty list because it has no
Styles and it has no options all right
listen let's break off a discussion
about how to do how to deal with
metadata in trees
because I think we need to solve that
okay
can you can you try and have a think
about that and come back with some
proposals for that
yes because without that all of these
are going to be confused
now you've also got some other things
here
um
what are your other things you've got
the text element and Trace what are you
doing with Trace now
so Trace is doing the same thing as
Trace tree
okay but how do I give it input
do trace of some expression
and then do expression tree of that
comma drink Trace
well it's interesting I mean does it
have all of those fancy things about um
uh you know red dashed lines and all
that kind of stuff
no only only the graph representation
had those edges
the tree the tree representation doesn't
have edges for transformation rules
but so Trace Golf produces a richer
output than this
is that correct
I'd say equivalent
well it's not equivalent because one of
them has tagging for time like edges and
one does not
but you can infer what those edges are
from this tree I don't care it's not
showing that stuff
which you probably can't
unless maybe Trace graph should have an
option to also give a tree
um
look
look this whole area of kind of
application trees
seems like we need certain you know
broad ideas like how to display metadata
and then
what's the full inventory of types of
application type trees
that we're currently imagining I mean
another one
well I can imagine is like a data set
another
you can take a data set and do
expression tree comma data set
okay
okay well
what is the full list is it that's in
here
what's that
true you're well what's that where it
says graph what's that graph
yeah
that would be just a another way of
converting a tree into a graph it'd be
identical to just doing tree graph of
the tree
but this thing here is an expression
tree this is supposed to be a tree
what's it doing with the graph here
it would have to be a tree graph Q graph
I think it's in the opposite direction
this is to convert that graph into a
tree
yeah
and then tree expression would convert a
tree into a graph
okay
oh so sorry yes I misspoke I should have
said this would be the same as what
graft tree does more or less
okay
listen again we need to do a further
review that is based on having a way to
show metadata because all of these
things have mattered or many of these
things have metadata and we're not
displaying it properly
makes sense
yep
I also so I just want to see some real
operations done
you know like you know there's this
whole xslt language for dealing with XML
trees I want to see us do the things
with those
I want to see
things that have been traditional you
know notebook programming with all this
weird notebook locate and so on
mechanisms how can that be done using
tree programming on the notebook version
of a
tree expression
expression tree rather
do you see what I'm saying yep we're
looking into all of those things and
working on the design okay so like with
text element
I mean I'd like to know I don't know
take a take an operation that you might
do
on a sentence like I don't know one that
we care about now is enough for a
resolution getting rid of pronouns and
things
and see roughly even even in some very
hacky way what would you do structurally
on this text element expression tree to
deal with that
that makes sense
yep okay
all right we're going to go on for a few
minutes here
um
we've got a lot of stuff here
um and uh I need to push back my next
meeting by 15 minutes
and I expect that you might want to sort
of follow up on this
yeah I know we're not going to get it
all done okay so let's start off with
astral position because that's exciting
yeah so you can open the rough page
I mean this is a whole new world so to
speak
Yes actually I I recently realized that
the opposition is a very particular case
of anstral position we can do
we have things like geoposition XYZ the
opposition e and U Etc this is our all
particular cases of extra position wow
okay so I think the the simple two
whimsical
yes yes the the summary boxes is not
not good enough but uh we needed
something the thing is that as the
position needs to store uh quite a lot
of stuff so it cannot be shown directly
so try something that's the position of
some celestial object
and and remember that the first time
that we evaluate it will download data
if if you don't have the data already so
it may
it may decide to to unload
yep okay
so now how do I draw where that is in
the sky
for me
uh well try astral Graphics Point well
we do need white because otherwise it
will not
of that
of the extra position not not the entity
the answer should work right it should
work yes yes
okay so if I say point this thing here
and I say style of that
comma orange for example
now the thing is in which coordinates
disease right and so so coordinates are
not so obvious if if you know the
um no they're completely novice and
that's presumably the Milky Way exactly
yep kind of Wiggly
yep okay so so there are several main
coordinate systems to work with here and
by default we use what we call the
horizontal or Horizon frame essentially
Your Horizon is a horizontal line
and uh
in in in this coordinate frame and and
there is a part which is above a
particle which is too low so if you if
if you say for example try a position of
Pluto and now and the second argument
say equatorial then you will get this
the coordinates of Pluto but in the
equatorial frame okay
well the map is not going to change much
I I was saying astral position of Pluto
comicatoria and you see how the numbers
change
the string string quarterly
yet
right so now this is it's different
names and equatorial there are multiple
equatorial frames so it automatically
changes what's going on with these minus
signs yes
this is something we have to change in
quantity so mixed quantities show
independent signs for all the various
quantities and usually
yes but what I wanted to say is in the
in the equator and when you ask for the
position of Pluto it now gives the right
Ascension and declination
and
and
um
and and now
uh yes yes what I was saying is they are
referring to this so-called two
equatorial two Equinox frame so there
are multiple equatorial frames and you
you have to be specific about which one
it is
okay but but let me just uh I'm just
playing here yep yeah sure
okay so if I like the cosmic microwave
background that we have do we have the
data on that I mean do we can I can I
show that in them uh we don't have that
image yet but we will it will be one of
the types of Astra background
okay you can also increase the same
level of this image we have it goes up
to zoom eight right now how do I do that
I mean do I also have an astro swim
level
is that the right way to do it I mean is
is that because there's an astro is
there an astral range like Geo range yes
there is yes there is
but I could also do that by saying Astro
zoom level because that might be easier
to understand because I don't actually
know what the what the box is in terms
of of uh write Ascension declination so
but by default is now using one no
that's too much for the whole sky
but um oh I see yes you didn't set the
whole sky right
again because we don't recognize the
backgrounds using constellations Etc it
will look nicer so try astrographics of
Sagittarius for example
this here instead of this yes remove all
that
and do
uh Sagittarius
probably remove also the the rest of the
options
you know I don't think I've ever typed
the name Sagittarius in my whole life
do do a stop server equatorial
it's downloading data do
um
there is an option which probably which
is your name it's selecting the the
coordinates you are using for the
observation do after Observer equatorial
can I put scales on here
scales to frame goes to draw
and that's going to give you equatorial
coordinates
why is this
why is it zero though well these this is
using now the lamberta symmetal
projection that's like Geo it will
choose whatever Lamborghini the Lambda
simulator projection wants to use so
it's centered on on this so
I don't understand why they're on
absolute coordinates here
oh yes change the projection
do use a projection like equal
rectangular
this is a projection effect
yeah now you have the the coordinates
let me just take a look at what's
Happening Here
huh so I think I think it's um can we
have a look at the ref page of
I want to see this I mean yes so this is
something that Jeff is doing
do you want to explain Jeff
um sure uh we've got an intern that's
actually going through each of the
constellations and we're doing
illustrations as a possible option I
think optional background uh to these
things
um by default I think when we plot a
constellation I think we should just
show the stars and the stick figures I
think I think having illustrations by
default would be too much actual Bearer
is a little bit hard to Bear right
they're neat to do when you see them
individually but yeah but if you do the
whole Sky it's like it's going to look
very crowded let's kind of look forward
Babylonia
okay
uh
these are still coming along though
we're about halfway done with all the
constellations
oh we might may want to revisit a few
good tweaks to them but so if I say
Astro angular separation
I think it's
I think it's still called angular
separation in the X kernel I have to
rename it angular separation okay yes
and uh now do two bodies stand on the
moon or whatever Jupiter
yeah
oh well
yeah so sometimes it happens it needs
data
now obviously in the cloud we need to
know how this is going to work yes yes
Jeff has pointed out that multiple times
so I I don't know whether the fat
Colonel would have all that and where
are the units for that
um yes this needs to be changed at the
moment it's returning radiance
that I I do this just to to work better
on the performance of the functions okay
but it will return in degrees presumably
um I'm not sure the unit but yes
probably decrease probably it's better
quantity I think so 10 degrees Yeah so
this is angular separation at the moment
as observed from door from your location
okay what happens if I want to observe
it from Saturn
yeah China
so it should get closer together yeah
and if I observe it from
uh uh Alpha Centauri
it should be super close of servers at
the moment I think they are
restricted to be in the solar system
so there are so you kind of serve stars
but the observant itself at the moment
so if you want what do we have right now
okay it's it's a physics
it is something that knows the physics
of the solar system
right
but the geometry geometrically you
should be able to figure out the angular
separation from Alpha Centauri
yes yes the problem is that there are
there are computations he has involving
relativity Etc and when do gay when you
go very far from the solar system this
gets more tricky and that's a part that
they haven't figured out yet for example
there is nothing about cosmology here
this knows everything about light
deflection by the sun things like that
but right the angular separation of a
quasar from another Quasar is obviously
kind of kind of hard to compute right
right
so for example this computation when you
had if you put here this actually takes
into account your position on the earth
so if you go to the other side of the
Earth the numbers will change a bit
okay so if I go here so so let's say I
say
uh let's say I say London here
and then I say Sydney yeah
obviously I'm looking through the Earth
in in some of these cases exactly yeah
it may happen yeah cool
and these I mean this changed both
because you changed the position and
because the positions of the planet
changed and this was a period of time
yeah yeah this is very precise let me
let me try it again
my God
okay
I have no idea
and yet it moves as people have said in
the past
now this also takes into account for
example the fact that the position
is the position of
of the planet when the light was emitted
so this is doing also [ __ ]
computations
yep
yeah I understand and so so is there a
way of getting it um
so there are ways the The Observer
argument the second argument of us to
position is very powerful there are
there are examples in the ref page and
so you can specify things like
reflection
uh whether you want to correct
aberration because the Earth is moving
things are not
wow
really got that uh you've even got that
Addington example showing the um
what was that example you were showing
me earlier
yeah where you get that star
disappearing behind the Sun and you can
actually see the deviation
did you have that as an example Jose uh
yes I think it's it's here in in one of
the um
in one of the scope examples
and it's also in the ref page of Astro
angular separation
don't forget to report that as a
spelling word microaric seconds
well
yes these are all
um computations and these you are
looking at right now for example that
last one this geoposition e and u
the opposition dnu gives you a vector
from a location to another one on the
earth which is something that Astra
position can do but of course in order
to get the same result you have to undo
the the corrections so this Frame you
see lifetime aberration like deflection
you have to undo those things in order
to get micrometer agreement
huh
so that's saying I'm using the Horizon
frame meaning my XYZ access are aligned
with my North uh East up
I'm looking from here I'm not
considering refraction by the atmosphere
lifetime is geometric meaning it's
instantaneous not the correction of La
of the speed of light that we were
discussing before aberration false means
do not consider the velocities
and light deflection is do not consider
deflection by Massive bodies
so wait a minute so are we in fact going
to support the astrophysical and
cosmological versions of all of this
there is no cosmology at the moment but
there will be in the future I need to
figure out how to do it properly
right but I mean so for example
gravitational lensing will be something
taken into account if you have light
deflection Arrow true
gravitational lensing eventually yes
now gravitational lensing is something I
mean you are talking about Ray tracing
essentially so to create an image of the
individual race
that's hard so so this is Computing a
single light rate
that's not hard it's expensive right you
just because you have to do it many
times right yeah because Astro position
is not a you know a Galaxy
is an extended astral position so to
speak
exactly exactly
whereas after a position like
geoposition is a point exactly yep
so it has to be a sworn master of
positions that you're doing to have an
imaged gravitational lensing exactly
boy hopefully we'll have this stuff just
in time for when we actually start to
need to use it to actually have
computable features of our physics
project just think well I'm not asking
you to support variable Dimension like
propagation since we don't even know how
that works yet
um
but uh
yeah so this is great it's really
impressive
um there's a lot of physics in this
function
it has for example very precise models
of the Precision of the earth and
notation
how models of the Precision of of most
planets planets and moons
of how far
in the past and future years ago
the data we have from NASA for the earth
and the main planets goes 15 000 years
to the Past into the future
but for the moons it's it's much smaller
you know for some of the most obscure
moons it can be just a few decades
Although our amount is an exception of
that right I remains much yeah exactly
our one goes goes also thousands of
years but what about the procession I
mean
I don't even know the I mean the
procession of the equinoxes like like
you go back millions of years no I mean
the whole physical solar system is
unknown exactly Beyond a few tens of
millions of years yes for the Precision
we have very good models for hundreds of
years
uh models that can go back a few
thousand years but not much more it
becomes very unpredictable
right
right there are some people have studied
more and there are these studies of the
milankovic cycles and things like that
sure
but what are we going to do so we have
some sensible message that just says we
don't have data going if you ask for
this you know in the Cretaceous Period
or something it's just going to say we
don't have that data exactly that that's
a possibility and another possibility is
to have a mixture of models at the
moment it's always going for the most
precise model we have meaning that's the
only we have so the the idea is is to
find other even approximate or
interpolate extrapolated models or
something like that yeah
well this is making my day this is
really cool stuff
the I except I want to I want to see it
so you're saying
so can I get a picture of what the sky
looks like from the subs of the moon for
example is that easy to do
um well the background image we have is
considered to be the same for all
um
as long as you're in the solar system
The Parallax is not enough that you
would visually see much difference
although you could argue that maybe okay
but but even just um
uh the correct orientation to the Luna
Horizon
how do I see it
how do I see it from the Apollo 11
Landing site right now
I see so um let's see I I think I
haven't tried this yet so let's let's
try astral graphics
um let's do gear range
oh sorry joined astral range all so that
it gives the the whole sky
and then let's do let's we have to
define the abstract server so this is
where where
right so I have to Observer
and and so here we will need first the
frame it will be the horizontal frame so
string sorry list string Horizon
so this defines that we are going to be
using the heart the Horizon frame of
some object now the date so do date goes
to now
I say date goes to now okay yes
and now the location is where we have to
say
aware so use a place in the Moon
um
yes so this is
yeah no it doesn't work this this will
work this will do what you want but yeah
I just realized it it's not doing
okay but but somehow
this whole thing about the frame Horizon
versus right Ascension declination
whatever else it is it doesn't seem to
me like this is the right option for
that it seems like that should have its
own separate option
it could be so do you see that in order
to
to define the things you need two things
the physics and the maths the physics is
where when and in which orientation the
math is then and I want this in
cylindrical coordinates
the in in Cartesian coordinates
left-handed or right-handed special
coordinates this type of thing and so
that's why there is the abstract server
on one side and then there is the
projection
in astral position there are three
arguments so the second one is the
Observer the physics the third is the
coordinate system the maths
right I mean I think it's a little
strange
the place right which which could all be
packaged in a in a Geo position actually
or an astral position for that matter
all of that stuff the location and the
date that's all part of an astral
position isn't it
yes it's it's a it's it's an event of
observation yes it could be
okay but but then the Horizon thing is
its separate issue
the fact that we are
I mean that to me is closer to the
projection story
yes but the Horizon depends on the event
because the Horizon is different from
one place or another
for example it it also depends on the
date because the Earth is rotating
so it has to be all together if we just
say Horizon but we don't know the event
we know nothing yeah except you've got
here and now
by default yeah
but if you want something else I know
but I mean Here and Now is like I'm
looking out of my window what do I see
typed exactly yep
um
so just so I understand
in
so we already should have and I've never
tried this this will be a good demo
maybe we've actually we did try it when
we were looking at that um
uh
given a location
right
as you know Apollo 11 descended to the
moon so to speak there is we should be
able to show
kind of the view out of the window at a
certain height
now one of the things we don't generally
have is the viewport
for viewing
am I making sense you know normally when
we have a view of the Earth
we're just imagining that it's a full
aperture you know view of the earth
there's no yeah I'm just
um I mean we must have done this when we
were trying to track that Israeli
spacecraft that had that stuff of ours
on it that um the one that unfortunately
crashed into the moon we did we did
figure out things from its trajectory I
think we were doing it just from
locations geolocations above the Moon
geopositions above the Moon
so okay so then then this potentially is
a geoposition or an astral position
and
so I mean let's say I want to look
towards the Earth
is that easy to specify here
I'm I'm hanging out on Mars and I want
to look towards the Earth
yes so the the syntax would be but it
will not produce yet the the images you
are expecting but it will be the
astrological you couldn't say Earth
depth of server could be the Moon so
that would be the
Moon center of the Moon looking towards
the center of the Earth by the Astro
Center with the Earth
um yes that that can be too so a center
like in geocenter is a way of specifying
the range
part of the information of the range
in in with in maps you can say geocentre
is London Geo range is is so many
kilometers
so here would be a similar thing we can
say this look in direction of the center
or something with with an aperture of so
many degrees
right
but again you are thinking of something
that we would require Ray tracing
or or 3D so if we had all these in 3D it
would be much easier to do these
computations because it will be done via
however
doing it in 2D will produce just a I
don't know a gray Circle or something
like that
yes
well that's a good start
um
okay uh
perhaps you want to look at some
examples in the Astro Graphics page
sure just for a second here and I know
I'm late here we'll have to continue
this another time this is lovely though
um
just scroll down
so these are some of the images that we
were discussing before
so the these this is also a fun example
we see merged in retrograde motion
when do I ever see the Milky Way and
this I I mean this is a very weird
projection because I mean if I'm looking
at the sky the Milky Way Milky Way is
always appears to me straight doesn't it
yes because you are using Horizon
coordinates this is always in Equatorial
do you say after server it goes to
katoria the problem with the Horizon
accordion is that they keep changing all
the time so it's very difficult to
orient yourself
while the equatorial view is always the
same I see
but so you'd still see retrograde motion
if it was Horizon coordinates you'd
still see retrograde motion exactly it's
just that these points will be oriented
in a different direction
okay
and why
okay
and and this is the plane of the
ecliptic is that true exactly
more or less yeah
so there is a better example further
down with all the main planes
so these are the the four planes you see
there with four colors so the ecliptic
is in green
Horizon is in blue the galactic
obviously is brown
and the purple is the equator of the
Earth
why is the Horizon circular
this is this is this stereographic
projection in the stereographic
projection planes are always circles or
straight lines yeah
and further down there is the economic
projection in which all the planes are
always straight lines
doesn't look great it's a complicated
projection
but here you see the four main planes
each one with its own set of coordinates
Etc
so I mean somehow if we take a random
star catalog and things this is like
going to give us
I mean
you know you look through a telescope at
a tiny piece of sky and the telescope is
effectively and and you make a plate or
whatever whatever the modern version of
that is yep that is some kind of
projection of the sky onto a plane
and one of these projections is that one
is that correct
when you're looking at a very small area
of the sky
it's like when do we use a very low
Scale map it's always essentially the
Mercato projection it's always in the
end the same
this is our scale projection projections
are very important what you want to
represent the full sky
yeah then they make an enormous
difference
but so so now in this case I mean like
okay so another thing we should be able
to do is plot a satellite on the sky
right instead of this we should be able
to put you know show the position of you
know random iridium satellite
you know is that does that work now
um I don't think it works now directly
so if we do compute the extra positions
then you can place the positions in
astral graphics so what Astro Graphics
doesn't do well yet is interpreting all
the possible entities we have I see okay
fine
okay but I mean the way that this will
work is you'll be able to show
you know for J random deep spacecraft
you'll be able to show
hopefully you know we will have we have
a bunch of those trajectories and we'll
have more
because
I mean I think being able to show the
trajectory of a spacecraft as observed
from the moon for example that should be
doable with all of this right yeah or a
spacecraft as seen from another
spacecraft should be doable with all of
this
yes indeed
um well it's lovely
boy
uh
so in this first released I think astral
Position will be as powerful as it may
be astrographics is still kind of far of
what it will get
but it would it will do the most basic
things but it will keep improving
fair enough
well I think this is lovely
well done yeah so
um
I think it'd be worthwhile to just
enumerate use cases that we're aware of
both um
uh
and they're presumably one's in Earth
orbit like for example from the ISS
where is you know
where is such and such a satellite as
seen from the ISS
presumably we can do that with all of
this yes yes we should be able to
as long as we have the extra positions
of things
meaning numbers in indefinite coding
systems we can do the computation
right
um
well good no excuse for any any of those
science fiction shows or anything to get
any of this stuff wrong anymore
um
okay all right we should wrap up for now
um
looks to me like we have another
um
yeah there's probably there's lots of
stuff coming from this right
uh that's in progress so let's see how
far we get so yeah not so much this time
[Music]
okay there's no design in particular
this time
okay okay no new functions so there are
some improvements in existing ones but
um
the main thing in Geo is still making
um the default V vector and um and
faster so that's still the main
detective fair enough okay so I think we
probably need a
um I think it wouldn't be bad to do
another little half hour or something on
the Astro stuff and just see if we can
clean a few more of these um indeed uh
uh options and things
um
all right but great stuff okay thanks a
lot guys see you all soon